hey i'm jasmine and welcome to tasty's
hack our hassle on the show tasty
producers try to make a dish using a
bunch of different hacks collected by
our friend annie today we're making
pancakes pancakes are great and they're
tasty and delicious i love using hacks
in the kitchen if it can save me time
and save me some dish washing then i'm
all for it
all right we have the control pancakes
with no hacks attached to this it is a
beautiful golden brown there's a good
slab of butter on there and it's sitting
in a puddle of syrup which we all
definitely like very much so it'll be
interesting to see how the hacks will
affect the appearance
[Music]
so we're going to start out with dry
ingredients first up is the flour and
this hack is to aerate it from higher up
than usual supposedly sifting it from
higher up will help aerate it that's
messy that didn't really seem worth
doing to be honest oh i got messy not
worth it gotta dry clean
now we're gonna add the baking powder
and the baking soda this is another hack
where you add a little more baking soda
so i think i'm just going to add like
maybe half a teaspoon more we'll see how
that turns out it's supposed to help
make it crispier and help it brown a
little better so this recipe calls for
buttermilk and there's a hack for that
if you don't have buttermilk at home you
can add some lemon juice supposedly
it'll start curdling in a minute or so
but
only time will tell that's taking a bit
of time so we're just going to set that
to the side and get to the next step so
today we are going to try separating the
egg yolk from the egg whites with a
slotted spoon this is the slotted spoon
we have for today we're going to crack
the egg into the slotted spoon and the
slotted spoon should catch the egg yolk
and the egg whites should drop out yeah
i got a good
two teaspoons of egg white out of the
slotted spoon and now they're just kind
of forming little bubbles on there for
the most part it caught the whole egg so
given the fact that the egg is still
fully in the spoon i would say that this
hack is a fail the next egg hack calls
for this funnel and a plastic water
bottle it's already not very
eco-friendly which i'm not a big fan of
we are going to put the funnel
in the water bottle crack the egg and
it'll catch the egg yolk and the egg
whites will drop into the water bottle
it seems that the egg yolk has cracked
and gone through the funnel not sure if
that was my doing even then look at the
egg white it's just stuck there oh it
all went down bad no pass fail got an
extra egg just gonna go with the tried
and true method here this last egg hack
involves whipping the egg whites until
soft peaks form which is a similar
process to the fluffy japanese pancakes
i'm not gonna do that over the head
trick but we got some soft peaks now
that the eggs are done i'm just going to
check back on the buttermilk it didn't
curdle that's concerning so now we're
going to combine these three ingredients
we're going to start with the buttermilk
i guess it did curdle not much but it
did curdle now we're going to add in the
egg yolks and the melted butter this is
a hack apparently it will help slow down
gluten development and help it brown a
little more i'm not really sure if this
is a hack because i feel like most
pancake recipes i've used have called
for melted butter now we're going to add
a little bit of vanilla extract all
right now this hack is to add a bit of
orange blossom water i've never had
orange blossom water before so this next
hack involves adding some unflavored
sparkling water to the batter it's
supposed to make it lighter
hassle
big hassle well the show goes on
i'm like shaking now i have no idea how
this is supposed to work we'll see how
it affects the pancakes so now we're
going to add in our wet ingredients to
our dry oh i smell the orange now we're
going to gently fold in our egg whites
and for this hack we are going to leave
it slightly lumpy make sure not to leave
it too too lumpy so the batter is done
this hack says to rest it at room temp
for 30 minutes instead of using it
immediately most batters i make do call
for resting it so can't hurt
we are ready to start making the
pancakes the recipe calls for a cast
iron but this hack is to use a
non-stick skillet and to coat the bottom
of the pan most people use cooking oil
spray or just oil but this hack is to
use butter supposedly the butter will
help the pancakes brown better and give
it more flavor butter does burn easier
though so you got to be careful on the
timing for this i got the batter i have
transferred it into this squeeze bottle
this is the other hack i've cut the tip
a little bigger maybe that'll make the
pancakes prettier i'm going to try this
a couple of ways i'm going to do one
where i just squeeze it in the center
and i'm going to do one where i do a
little swirl oh well that's an ugly
pancake the hack was to leave the batter
a little more lumpy but i think it just
didn't work out for me i couldn't see
the loose flower i thought it would hold
its shape but it didn't and now again i
have more things to wash and if you've
ever washed a squeeze bottle it's not a
fun time we're going to grab some syrup
and we're going to pour it directly onto
one of these pancakes so the next hack
is to flip the pancakes when bubbles
form on the surface i don't think it's
ready to flip it's like very flimsy
it wasn't ready to flip look at that
she's so sad the sparkling water was
supposed to help it crisp more and i do
see the edges crisping quite nicely they
look a little bit oily that might have
been me putting too much butter but they
do look more oily than they should be
i'm gonna make two more pancakes but
this time with this
i saw this a bunch of times on tick tock
we all love a good tick tock hack it
showed them making the perfect pancake
to the point where it looked like fake
food you know i already want to give
this my stamp of approval because it's
so cool and look at how pretty these
pancakes are it's like a perfect circle
i've also seen people use this for like
cake batter cupcake batter there's
measurements on the sides so it seems
pretty versatile which i like okay let's
flip this look it kept shaped so well
all right pancakes done i'm gonna put on
a separate plate now let's see how they
stack against the control pancakes
here i have my hack pancakes next to my
control pancakes first impression these
are thicker the hack ones are much
thinner the control one does not have
crispy edges the hack ones do the extra
baking soda was supposed to help it
brown better i actually think it took
longer to brown than normal so i would
lose that so the bottom of this pancake
stack actually has the syrup infused one
so i'm gonna try that one first before
adding syrup to the rest
it tastes like an orange vanilla cake i
would actually expect to get this at a
fancy la brunch spot for the blossom
water i would say it depends on your
taste if you want to add that extra
dimension to it go for it if you are
looking for a classic pancake omit it i
would still be adding syrup on top of
that i'm like looking for the flavor of
the syrup and if you remember we coated
the pan with butter instead of oil or
oil spray i wouldn't say the extra
butter was worth it because you know
that fresh slab of butter on top of your
freshly made pancakes so so important to
the experience if you put this in front
of me i would think it's a diet pancake
so these have the whipped egg whites
which was supposed to make them lighter
fluffier but they actually seem to be
much thinner i would just skip it it's
more work in the kitchen than it needs
to be i'm actually going to taste the
control pancake
mmm that's a pancake
give me a minute yeah that's a pancake
and i like the floppiness of this
pancake it seems to be fluffier than the
hack pancakes okay i'm gonna try my
perfect pancake now
there's a nice crisp this one didn't
taste overwhelmingly buttery as the one
that was infused with syrup did if you
remember we added melted butter to this
pancake batter feel like it doesn't hurt
i would say go for it for the buttermilk
hack i do feel like it curdled but i'm
not sure if it curdled enough i'm
thinking if you don't have time to go to
the store to get buttermilk it's a good
alternative but if you do have time to
go to the store and get some buttermilk
i would go with that overall i feel like
this is a good pancake but if i'm
dreaming about a pancake i'm dreaming
about these but we have a few more
pancake hacks so let's get to it
so this next hack is something i've been
very curious about and it's using cookie
cutters to shape your pancakes i've been
doubtful because i just can't imagine
that the batter won't run out the sides
but we'll see i'm just going to go for
it
it's running out the sides not bad
though all right i'm gonna do it for
this one they're looking pretty good
though i will say i'm gonna attempt to
flip this
yeah it does work i'm so happy the edges
aren't very clean but that's my own
fault because i put too much batter in
the cookie cutter oh it's so cute i
think this hack was definitely a success
next time i would just use a little less
batter
all right next hack is the tick tock
famous pancake cereal i put the batter
in a squeeze bottle but this time i did
not cut the tip for this one you got to
make sure you have some smooth batter
tik tok makes this look very easy but in
theory it's very tedious i thought the
chopsticks would be helpful but they're
not the ones that are too small are
really hard to flip this is already out
of my element because they're so tiny
all right this is looking done it's so
bare the bowl should i make more
i made another batch to make this bowl
look a little less sad and i will say
the second batch came out a lot better i
think it's just you know got to get a
hang of it now we're just going to add
some butter and of course can't forget
the syrup it is cute i actually want to
take a picture see i'm all happy now
that i've made it it was just a process
getting here all right yeah let's mix it
up
this probably is equal to like one
pancake
i'm ashamed to say i approve it's a fun
way to eat pancakes actually the only
difference i would make is to use smooth
batter
here are our last two unconventional
pancake methods one with the sheet pan
and one with a rice cooker i'm gonna
start by pouring half my batter into the
sheet pan
though obviously going into this i am
expecting the texture to change just
gonna roll it around to make sure it's
all coated
and i'm just going to add blueberries on
one side and chocolate chips on the
other i think that looks good now i'm
going to prep it in the rice cooker
the rice cooker really does it all i saw
this on tiktok they literally just
poured the pancake batter in there let
it cook and it was done in like 20 30
minutes so that's what we're gonna do
both the pancakes are set so it's time
to let them cook
it's done
it looks really good obviously it
doesn't quite look like a pancake but
looks quite crispy on these corners ooh
looks more like a pancake now gonna add
some syrup i'm gonna see how it tastes
it's good but it doesn't quite taste
like what i'm thinking a pancake would
taste like i understand this hack for
convenience steak but i probably would
not
do it all right our rice cooker pancake
is done let's take this out
and you are supposed to flip it just do
a little flip ugh
wow oh my goodness it's adorable first
impressions texture wise it looks great
it does look nice and moist very buttery
it's so big all right let's give this a
try off the bat i can already tell it's
more cakey
that's pretty good i like that one more
than the sheet cake
so we're done with all the pancake hacks
i would honestly say most of them were
flops sorry but my top three favorites
were number one the orange blossom water
number two
the dispenser for the batter number
three the rice cooker method thanks for
watching and if you have any other
pancake hacks leave them in the comments
below bye
[Music]
you